[音楽]
[拍手]
ああそうだ
今日の帰りにスーパーによってこれを買っていかなくちゃ
店等
卵と
結成軍で撮っ
ああそれからケチャップ等
あー産業はあっ
3皆さんからこのメッツの炭鉱どうやって覚えますか
頭の中で繰り返し何と孫請け白目
3世魂の消し米と復唱しますか
それとも覚えるまでひたすらん紙に書き続けますか
まるでめかして受けた機テストのようで嫌な気持ちになる方も多いでそう
千代キュッと聞くとどうしても試験や
詰め込み9条といった印象を抱くと思います
今日を今日はその悪いイメージを払拭するために行ってますか
みなさんはもうここに座った以上僕の話から逃げることはできません
なのでこの苦情を後で実際にやってもらえることができちゃうんですね
おだむすび
僕は記憶力で基礎やメモリースポーツとりあえずの競技の選手もやります
大会電話例えば護符や10
を決められた制限時間内に
なんだ目に並んだ沢山の数字やートランプ
単語など覚えてその両方基礎やっています
ちなみに僕は一変感があれば50個の単語をすべて
順番通りに覚えることができます
どれだけたくさんの介護を頼まれても忘れることはありません
皆さんはこの協議のことを球場だと思うでしょうか
違うんですよ僕はこれを心の底から楽しいと思ってやっているんです
楽しさをわかってもらうために共同の記憶テストに戻りましょう
今度は単語を使って遊んでみます
れっつの単語を順番通りに使って自由に楽しいストーリーを想像妄想するんです
今から僕も妄想を皆さんにお話するので皆さんは脳内でイメージしながら聴いて
ください
ものにイメージをするというところがポイントです
目を閉じても構いません
皆さんはスーパーマーケットの入り口まで行ってきました
でもこの改造から歩いてスーパーまで行ったので
疲れています
枯れたので入り口の前に座り込みコップに水を注いで休憩しました
水お洋服見てみるとなぜか卵が孵化ぷかん向いていま
愛知になりますよねその卵を手にとって終わってみるとなんと中から消しゴムが出てき
ました
そしてその消しゴムが多くの中に落ちてしまいました
消し米が水に濡れてしまったのでファウルで吹きました
孔玉
そういえばこのために自分の名前を書いてなかったなって思っ
なぜか道に落ちていたケチャップを拾ってそのタオルにケチャップで自分の名前を
大きく書きました
するとケチャップが羽で髪の毛についてしまったのでその場でシャンプーをして
洗い流しました
想像できたんでしょう
今も作業は苦しくはなかったと思います
詰め込んだわけでもないですよね
ただ自由 d ストーリーをつけていただけです
実はこれがメモリースポーツでやっていることなんです
それでは実際にさっき覚えた単語を思い出してみましょう
選んだストーリーありますよねもう作ったストーリーを頭の中で最初から再生してみる
です
エッセイパーになってきましたん
一番最初あなたは何をしません
そうですよねほっぺに水を注ぎますか
なので一つ目の単語は水だったんですこういう風にして思い出していきます
次に何が起こっているのが見えましたん
ちょっと卵がプカプカんがんでるのが見えたはずです
なので2つめの単語は魂の
こうやってどんどん思い出せ
卵の中からしごめんが出てきてタオルって
吹いてケチャップ名前を書いて
最後に三平で新井貴した
簡単でしょ
今やっていた事って詰め込ん電気を消したわけではないのに不思議と覚えちゃってた
はずです
これも差勝ち本家の本質なんです
記憶って本来辛いものではなくて楽しいことを想像しながらを得られる
クリエイティブな作業なんです
方法はストーリー法と呼ばれる立派な記憶術でポケモン世界のトップ選手も協議で使っ
ている的人気の一つです
選手たちはこのようなテクニックもたくさん学んで練習して
時には自分であなたの記憶術を開発することで覚えられる量を日々増やしています
記憶ってテクニックなんです
記憶の選手をや体と言うとほとんどの人からだから記憶力がいいんですねと言われます
それを違います元からの記憶力は関係ありません
僕は単に後天的に身につけられる記憶術を使って覚えているんです
僕は大学生になってからこの記憶術を知り
メモリースポーツを始めました
どうしてこんなにマイナーで不思議な世界に足を踏み入れ
その理由をこれからお話しましょう
僕は梅雨が家工房と移ると早押しクイズをやっていません
高校生の時に地方大会でいいところまではいけてみ
全国で戦えるレベルに上がれませんですか
でもずっと日本一という消防に憧れていて
医学生になったらいつか日本一になりたいなと願っています
そこでどうやったらクイズが強くなれるんだろうって考えたときに
たくさんのものをは止めて覚えられれば強くなれるんじゃないかって思ったんですね
塩気を武器にしたいって思ったんです
そして調べていくうちに起業家術というものがあることを知りました
そして記憶術を使って競いあるメモリースポーツという競技も知りました
大いにもメモリースポーツの選手から直接記憶術を習うことができ
僕が競技を始めました
これが本当に楽しかった
今まで苦しんできた木を着せれっていう作業がこんなにも楽しくて
クリエイティブなものだってはなって何でもタイプ調べなかったんだろう
投稿公開しました
記憶術に才能は関係ありませんやればやるほど面白いように記憶できる量が伸びていく
んです
いつしか僕は記録術やメモリースポーツ
d のめり込むようになりました
始めたきっかけば記憶力があればクイズに役立つなと思ったからです
でも
続いたきっかけはしよく自体の楽しいと思えたからなんです
これがすごく大事だなと感じました入り口は何でもいいんです
僕ははじめ木桶をクイズのためのべき
つまり四段にしてみました
でもやっていくうちに記憶すること自体に喜びを覚えてきたんです
そう目的になってきたんです
木桶が手段からそれ自体のために頑張れる目的になって憶えられる量がどんどん増えて
きました
そして競技を始めて10カ月がたったとき
が記憶力の日本大会に出場しません
そこで僕はまさかの準優勝になります
木崎から
クイズで目指せなかった日本一に記憶でだったらなれる気がする
を意識するようになったんです
そこで僕はクイズを止め記憶に専念することにしました
ん
をやって楽しみながら記憶を続けているうちに普及活動にも力を入れるようになったん
です
こんなに面白い起業家の世界をもっとたくさんの人に伝えたいと思ったからです
少しずつですが教わりたいという人も増えて一緒に練習をしていきました
そのうちありから平田さんなら次は絶対日本一になれますよ
というレベルにまでなりました
そんな頃
あれ方からこう言われたんです
普及をするなら
日本一じゃないと誰も注目してくれない
の言葉が桶の未来を大きく変えてしまうことになりました
ん
確かに日本兄が教える記憶術では説得力は無いなぁとも納得しました
日本一になって記憶を普及させたい自分の助けるがすごいということを証明したい
昔からの夢だった日本一という性分を手に入れたい
そう願うようになったんです
ここまではまだよかったんですか
どうしても日本一じゃないと誰も注目してくれないよというのはも一言が引っかかって
いて
1位じゃないとヒロけっていう自分のアイデンティティ
すらも失われてしまうんじゃないか
自分は記憶力日本一にならないと
海のない存在なんだと思うようになってしまったんです
ここから向けは変わってしまった
今までより練習を重ね日本一になることだけを考えていました
どうやったら日本一になれるかどうやったらない晴れより恩恵を覚えられるか
それだけを考えて毎日トレーニングをしていました
あれからの平田さんから日本一になりますよという応援の言葉もむしろ煩わしく思い
絶島脳裏に日本一じゃない取りに行かない
というあの一言が刻み込まれていましたん
毎日何時間も練習をして何百桁の数字を覚えてそれでもずっと本当に自分って日本一に
なれるんだろうか
どう自問自答する日々
覚えたいという欲求は完全に消え覚えなきゃいけないというプレッシャーの中で練習を
していたので
気づけば広くが楽しくなくなっていたんですよ
それ自体魅力的で目的だった記憶スレっていう作業がいつのまにか
日本一になるためだけの手段に成り下がっていたんです
そんな触れ c 練習に体液
本大会のでようやく宴の後する術どうなったとき
僕は体を壊しました
激しいずつ止まらない吐きて今までに経験したことのないくらいの痛みを抱えてしまい
ました
yeah まあストレスでした
多すぎるプレッシャーに体が耐え切れなくなっていたんです
それでも動きは日本一にならなくてはいけないとか
文字通り体を引きずってぜを張ってでも大会会場の7件まで行かなくてはいけなかった
んです
お掛けして分かるので会場まで迎えましたん
会場では知り合いの選手がたくさんいましたが僕は高齢を立っています
全員が敵に見えて倒さねばならない相手だと思っています
大会が始まり性と気力をしているときだけは体の痛み思わせる
いうことができました
指定結果は generation
日本一に上がれませんでした
僕はこの時なんて愚かなことをしたんだろう凍気がつきました
明けて初めて記憶を手段にしていたことに気がつきました
楽しいはずの毛を気が楽しくなかったことに気がつきました
木桶て本来楽しいものなんです
僕は心を入れ替えて自分が楽しいと思える練習だけをしようと決意しました
そして日本一になることを意識せず
前世にもっとたくさんのものを覚えてみたいと思うようになったんです
そこで既存の記憶術の一つを改良し自分のためだけのオリジナルの基本技術を開発し
ました
この作業がめちゃくちゃ楽しかった
自分の脳みそにあった木を消すと作るというのはとてもクリエイティブでわくわくし
ました
それを使った練習も楽しかったです
木桶の不敵に戻ってきた瞬間ですか
そしてをも記憶術を駆使して3ヶ月後に
ジャパンオープンと呼ばれれもう一つの日本大飼にせずをしてました
そこでは選手たちと積極的に高齢をして日本一になりたいと言うじゃねえも完全に捨て
て
楽しみながら競技に臨みました
その言語
日本一になれました
優勝した時にこんな簡単なことだったんだな
同期ができません
僕はこのことも皆さんに知ってほしいんです気をつけて楽しいということ
そして記憶でも何でも手段じゃなくて目的として楽しんでほしいということ
日焼けてつまらないという既成概念を払拭して楽しいものなと気づいてほしい
入り口は何でもいいんです
テストのテストの成績が上がりそう仕事に役立つと日本一になりたい
どんな理由で記憶を始めたってそれは正解です
でもそれだけじゃじゃじゃないんです
どこかで塩気て楽しいなとかこれだけで十分自分の趣味なって思えるようにならないと
続かないし上達しないんです
鈍感皆さんに記憶自体をもっと楽しんでほしいんです
そして結果を出すために頑張らなきゃいけないという既成概念も結束してそれ自体を
目的にしていいなと気づいてほしい
皆さんにも今頑張っていることを目的にしてほしい
それ自体をもっと本気で楽しんでほしいんです
どうか結果を出したいという思いだけにとらわれないでください
本当に自分が楽しいと思えること本当に自分がやりたいと思う練習をしないと結果にも
つながりません
これが僕が来おけるく日本一になって気づいた大切なことです
開けて楽しいということが伝わったでしょうか
それでは最後にみなさんにテストをしもそう
最初に覚えたメンツの単語全部覚えていますか
スーパーに行って何を感じでしたっけ
きっと楽しみながら覚えた皆さんから全部思い焦るはずです
それが起業家の力です
今何かを頑張っていてもし辛いことがあったらさっきの買い物レストだけじゃなくて僕
のこのスピーチの内容も一緒に思い出してくれると嬉しいです
ありません
[音楽]
[拍手]